the latest on the deadly wave of
tornadoes that swept across multiple
States over the weekend the damage is
immense and at least 33 people were
killed between Friday and Sunday the
Twisters hit hardest over a huge area
from Illinois to Alabama all the way to
Delaware one County in Tennessee
reported nine deaths Arkansas has
declared a state of emergency five
people died there Omar via francas and
the capital of Arkansas where there is
considerable damage Omar good morning
good morning more than 50 people in the
Little Rock area were injured when an
ef-3 tornado rolled through here that's
wind speeds of up to 165 miles an hour
and check out this damage the roof is
gone the walls are knocked down even the
street steel structure here has
basically been bent this was all part of
a system that rolled through the South
and the Midwest
over the weekend the deadly storm system
ravaged communities from Iowa two
tornadoes on the ground to Delaware this
is crazy
around 260 people were inside of this
packed heavy metal concert venue in
Belvedere Illinois Friday when an ef-1
tornado with 100 mile per hour winds
swept through causing the roof to
collapse it just came in seconds one
person was killed and dozens of others
were injured the death toll was highest
in Tennessee where more than a dozen
people died nine people were killed in
rural McNairy County
in Arkansas a man captured the moment a
tornado swept over his van outside
little rock around 100 miles to the
Northeast the small town of Wynne
Arkansas has been reduced to Rubble we
knew all day something was coming we
didn't know it was going to come
directly for us this is what's left of
Curtis mcnelly's house this is my son's
bedroom he hid from the tornado in the
hallway of his home with his two kids
wife and mother-in-law and we're all
just hunkered down praying praying to
God that's when he says the wind ripped
the roof off his house my daughter we
told her to keep her head down but she
got her head up and she looked up and
she told me she thought we're in heaven
with angels
she thought it was over she thought it
was done
for a while I did too
President Biden issued a disaster
declaration for the state which should
help free up recovery funds and that
last check more than 13 000 customers
were still without power Natalie
just devastating to see all that
destruction Omar thank you so much